Hillsdale Academy is about developing
young people towards adulthood the true
liberal arts education is about raising
up young men and women to full humanity
they have been blessed with reason they
have been blessed with Souls what we
want to do is to help shape those
aspects that make them particularly and
beautifully human we want to focus on
those aspects to raise them up to be the
kinds of human beings the kinds of
adults we hope they would be first and
foremost of course the school is an
academic institution everything that
goes on in the classroom
is designed to help them develop the
kind of reason the minds that they ought
to have to strengthen the ability to
reason I get to teach kids science and I
get to teach it at a high level and I
know that from from top to bottom the
students are you know really getting
something out of it and we're not only
focused on you know them learning facts
we're trying to train them to really be
good thinkers we're simply going back to
the roots of who we are as Americans who
we are as a people as citizens living
under a constitution every Wednesday we
are gathered together for Chapel it
focuses our week it focuses our efforts
and our work our mission we can talk
about God we can talk about faith we can
actually look to Holy Scripture and that
is something that is not available in
most public schools the lessons learned
here are lessons that we aspire for our
kids to learn at home and they're
reinforced here those lessons of hard
work discipline character and a love of
learning those things are really
fostered here it's a very nice
experience because you learn more than
just academic skills you learn how to
how to build your character how to be
nice to people how you get along with
people when I think of the Academy it's
a very large portion of my life it
really feels like a family it's part of
how I grew up and it's part of all of my
friends that I made my classmates and I
we were good friends we were friends
with our teachers and there was just
that comfort that allowed learning to
occur I was so prepared for college it
made the transition easy we also have a
strong athletic program and the athletic
program is designed to support the
school's primary mission which is its
academic activities in athletics it's
been fun to watch this grow from
programs that we barely have enough to
feel the team to watch it go from there
to the point where we've had teams that
are competing for state titles and
operating at a high level
Hillsdale Academy is part of Hillsdale
College we have the opportunity to use
the athletic facilities we have the
opportunity to use the library our
students have the opportunity to walk 5
minutes and take a college class we're
part of not just the Hillsdale Academy
mission but we're part of the Hillsdale
College mission Hillsdale Academy serves
as a model for America in that what we
will do is work with a group of parents
a group of local citizens or a school
that is already in existence all of whom
want to model what we're doing in their
neighborhoods we went to Hillsdale
Academy to see what that was all about
and we're just thrilled to find a
coherent program that was really about
developing the entire student with a
longer view than just what's you know
for college or career but about the
whole person dr. Calvert has spent a lot
of time encouraging us and guiding us
and providing mentorship for me and for
our board as we've moved forward then
with the founding of the school our
faculty will come down and visit
Hillsdale Academy their counterparts in
the faculty department and spend time in
their classrooms here I'm grateful for
the opportunity that we've had to to
have the relationship that we've had
over the over the last four years when I
came in the Academy was already 12 years
old and many of its traditions its
dedication to the liberal arts and to
academic strengths were already
established through the help of many
good people in the staff with my
assistant Mike Roberts and so many of
the parents who were here and believed
in the mission of this school I felt
that together we were all able at that
point to move ahead and continue to
strengthen and to promote that important
mission I've been at the Academy this is
my 23rd year it's a wonderful place I've
had such joy over the years and
stability in my life knowing that I come
to such a special place every day
working with great kids great
administration and fellow teachers we've
been blessed with a great group of
people who have been able to maintain
the strong mission for for 25 years
truly remarkable